[Music]
with Darren brand can you just say your
full-name to the microphone please
Darren brand yes they like a politician
Darren bran wearin brand
welcome to the hot breath averse my man
what's happenin bro was head in a record
time yeah which we're trying to do the
video to swim who knows what it'll be I
love you hey it in right here
I gotta find what looks to my opinion
how you gonna look thin in a wife-beater
I don't know bro I don't know we could
straight they get all this make it out
as Billy come on all up let's make it
happen I appreciate you man here man out
of here in the ATL my favorite city in
the world is it really my favorite city
in the world why is that um there's not
many places where you could take a a for
weed in and see vagina and titties and
nips and have a great conversation and
hear the best new trad music is this
where you got kinda are you started in
north carolina but would you travel to
Atlanta a lot nope nope I started all
and everything in my career started
North Carolina man started with a group
called freestyle funny comedy show me
chico being b dot he's also a former
cast member Wilin out and he has a radio
station at home in north carolina one or
two jams and another comedian by the
name of sama been drinking from
charlotte north carolina also works on
one or two jams so you know we have you
know two guys who do radio in the
morning two guys who are you know
currently now on Wilin out and we're the
first comic show comedian I'm in a
comedy show I believe that has stand-up
and improv mixed together
well yeah it's like a two-hour show we
have crowd interaction games and we
really built this platform for colleges
because they worked well but colleges
colleges weren't crazy for it but uh as
of right now we were so busy
individually it was kind of hard to get
back on the road like we needed to but
that's how I started my career
I started around 2008 I started doing
our first knackers
you know the booking agencies colleges
started doing that about 2008 2009 I
quit my job I want to say when I quit my
job bro 2008 it's at Walgreens
yeah well 2013 yeah so I did stand-up in
comedy I was a full time I was a manager
I had my own store
so for five six years I did stand-up
comedy and I was a manager at Walgreens
you were a manager yeah like with the
dred yeah yeah see see see
they paid raise hold you back well I'm
not profiling see that was very racial
if you broke a my huh that's how they do
it oh come on we'll slide that [ __ ] down
here in Atlanta buddy
but now yeah man that's what I did I
when I graduate from college
the that's right when a recession here
so it was real [ __ ] up uh-huh and now
you kind of had to take what you can get
and I didn't expect to be working in a
retail for that long yeah ain't no as a
manager like you really ain't no manager
you just got a set of keys you do
everything and everybody else dude we
just got access to certain [ __ ] and uh I
hated that job I hated that job but it
taught me a lot about my character I had
a dope-ass store manager who let me get
off for any shows I hadn't worked out
the schedule for me and uh you know
that's that's what happened that's where
we are you must have been a dope manager
though yeah yeah yeah I would say I was
I was one of those managers like look
you don't start no [ __ ] and I ain't
gonna be no [ __ ] you come here you do
your job we'll all get lunch well yeah
yeah listen let's get this this first of
all it's the [ __ ] up job so let's get
to it together you know you got some
people would just take it too serious
it's not that serious
we're we're stocking shelves [ __ ]
relax you know say it's drug test they
did they did they did they did they do
it so I was kind of in the clear for a
while and I and I really didn't smoke
like I didn't really smoke like that
till I was about to quit right like I
had like a couple of months live out
like you know what I started going their
high and then you know
none of my co-workers knew itself like
maybe one here bro are you hot yeah
that's how I know you bought the [ __ ]
quick and uh and for companies like that
you know do drug test it cost a lot so
no reason they would do a drugs if they
was looking for a reason to fire you but
I did my job you know you know people
listen my employees was cool and there
was no reason to bother me what was the
moment that made you actually quit you
know what man I was I had to be 2013 I
had got my first real check from comedy
like my first you know you know not the
$50 75 you know talking about the open
my same inner peace 35 clothes and you
know not those I got the first chick and
I graduated from North Carolina ANC was
the HBCU in Greensboro Aggies Aggies all
day and I got my first check from
Whistler Salem State and this is a the
school that bean and beat I went to and
they didn't book them which I don't know
why school I don't know why schools
don't book people who come from now but
they gave me my first thousand dollar
check for 15 minutes
I'm sorry ten minutes well they wanted
me to open up for ready grant whenever
that would get you ten minutes here's
your cheque thousand dollars and I was
like so that's like a hundred dollars a
minute like I ain't never seen it you
know Stanford actually for being funny
on stage I was okay okay so you know and
at the time Walgreens I was probably
making like 45 to 50 a year and uh after
taxes that could very well be your check
on any given to give a pay period and so
once I realized that that kind of money
was you know allowing them school
programs for comedy I was like okay just
can happen and that's how I started but
you've been all over as far as just your
image like I know you have a marketing
degree right right so you've clearly
been able to translate that to doing
comedy right I mean it's about getting
yourself out there man it's about being
you know hip to what's new you know I'm
I'm older but I'm gonna young in a young
environment you know with me forming the
colleges that keep you young being a
customer while I now that keeps you
young and uh it's just you know I just
know how to make I just know how to stay
in front of people's faces as far as the
marketing I got a dope-ass flower guy in
Greensboro diario Tunes take care all my
Flyers are graphics
my brother here PB&J he's in charge of
my branding we have a printing company
together we print our own line of
t-shirts everything's in the house so
along with
comedy I have my hands and other
businesses I'm part of next level we do
our own travel we take 200 people out of
Jamaica and Cabo stuff like that every
year so is that next level entertainment
yeah yep oh you just will book parties
and like yep yep homecoming we're known
for having one of the biggest homecoming
events for auntie we also we take people
to Dubai about 20 people to the by every
year well cuz travel is the new bug now
really yeah so why not make a little
money off of it so you'll just book
track you'll just like set up a whole
trip and then get people to buy into it
yeah and like I said of course make it
wet costs you get less cost efficient
yeah like he just like flew Cabo was
like maybe I think it's 500 per person
for Cabo you have to get your own flight
so it runs out to probably like a
thousand dollar trip but you know we get
a resort we tell them we think we can
get 200 people they reserve the rooms we
probably put it out there we make it
cost efficient and people come and plus
it helps that I'm such a prominent
person in North Carolina North Carolina
I'm the [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] in Okolona
uh-huh I'm working on other places but
no Carolina a lot of people [ __ ] with me
man I'm known throughout the ANC
community too
I perform a lot along Charlotte Raleigh
in Greensboro which is the bigger cities
in North Carolina and people just people
just want to be around and have a good
time so people don't know you really
outside cuz that's the weird thing about
comedy is like you if you're in the
comedy world oh my god so awesome and
then my wife might be like wait who is
that right right it's either or
sometimes there's people cuz I'm
affiliated with the 85 stop show which
I'm pretty sure you know yeah yeah yeah
I've been I've been out at gas stations
I had people come to me and be like amen
I recognized you from that show and I'm
like yeah why not a bloody hell they're
like what's that like oh my god 85 stop
show yeah so I've been a part of so many
avenues out there that helps and what's
crazy is and let me say this on here yes
I am all Wilin out and yes I'm a
comedian there's a lot of people who
don't realize that we're staying up
comedians on while at house a lot of
people who don't know a lot of people
think Chico bean is a rapper like he's
actually a stand-up comedian
you know everybody's not about a rapper
so you know this is clear that hear you
right now cuz it's people who come to
our shows like you was there Thursday or
Friday I didn't even know you did stand
out I'm like what
that's crazy unless you know that we
have so much further to go but that's
the rewarding part is when you they
think you this one thing and then when
you hit them with stand bow bow it's a
shock
yeah and then a lot of people think
we're younger cuz while I have a younger
cat you're gonna follow him and then
when I started talking about old [ __ ]
like getting beat by your parents or you
know sneaking to watch porn if this is
[ __ ] they headed a lie okay okay yeah
he's funny and [ __ ] I didn't know you
know I'm saying so hey that's dope
you got that hustle I mean did you pay
yourself through college yeah pay all
that yeah yeah I was in oh I was in the
ROTC military department believe it or
not uh-huh just trying to find a way to
pay for school and my sophomore year all
the people I was close to they were seen
as they said all in Afghanistan every
last one of them
I'm telling our females every one I was
like okay this [ __ ] is real so it's not
a game so you really don't care how I
feel okay ku and after that man I
withdrew from the program I think I owe
like 20 grand back sort of between the
government and the military and I paid
all that back like four years Athens
free free man you make it sound so easy
just not I wasn't easy I just I just
stayed with my aunt for a few months
after I graduated well it's right no
doubt I didn't I got a small apartment
that was kind of cheap uh-huh took it
out for a couple of years but yeah man
you know it's all part of the story
it helps what is probably the lowest
part of the story what was been your low
point so far lowest point man I would
say would be the second year after I
quit my job it was it was the first year
was crazy because it's amazing you know
I believe in God and I believe he lays
things down these things right in front
of you cuz you can ask my brother hi
fault quitting my job for like a year
cuz I was I'm so scared of being broke
and I've been I pay my bills I was like
no I'm not quitting I'm not quitting God
got rid of my position gave me a
severance package I got my income tax
check at the same time I was on I got
booked for the first twenty five college
nickel tour so I was just like okay and
I still didn't want to quit and I quit
and my friend [ __ ] was great was the
fray was up I made more money in my
first year than I quit when I quit then
I did when I had the job but my second
year
when the book is due to come back around
you know schools take a school second
chance like the first time the same
school not gonna book you the next year
so you gotta look for other schools and
it didn't roll like we thought it was
and it got low man funds got low it got
bad like I was like should I find
another job on the low should I do some
online telemarketing oh yeah but uh got
through it man and freestyle funny was
going through a transition
Chico had just made Wilin out so he was
always gone he was a starter group so we
needed his manpower to help for the
group and it was a tough time everybody
individually has stuff they want to
accomplish but still at the end of the
day it all worked out it worked out got
low it got low my didn't think money was
gonna come around but in that same year
I drove from Charlotte North Carolina to
New York ten hour drive to audition for
Wilin out - and I made it man
yeah and that's where he was sleeping on
the floor that's when I was I was
crashing in batting being room as a
extra as a side [ __ ] but I want the
[ __ ] out just like hey guys I did need
a place to lay down for a few hours of
yuku you know I'm saying I always owed
that to them man cuz when I first made
while I know I didn't make it as the
same way DC did because we came in the
same year the same with Matt right there
and it was like we [ __ ] with you we know
you being boy we [ __ ] with you but we
don't know what you can do so we're just
gonna promise your rehearsals so can you
get yourself up here so I was like all
right I booked my own flight I crashed
and being ruined in my first year out of
16 episodes I got 7 which is almost half
in a stand-up special so after that it's
been catapult look man no complaints so
you it's funny that you're on this TV
show that's very successful it's been on
like ten seasons and yet you'll see
smile in public and they're like oh I
heard you on that podcast yeah that's
right as a TV it's crazy
the world is so the world is so social
media friendly no no no a lot of people
you have to be a think about how hard it
is to sit down and watch a show today
yeah and not look at your phone or not
be occupied with something else
or just watch TV or listen to music it's
so hard to be engaged into a television
show unless you're a fan of or if it's
something you really want to see and so
I'm appreciative of the boat and I
understand both that's why I understand
I do
social media videos that's why I link
with other social media comedians that's
why also get on stage that's why I also
do Wilin out and it all helps man it all
helps in the long run yes social media
can be one thing and we are kind of
talking about this before but it's one
thing to have followers but another
thing to have a following right right
500 thousand followers and get 12 people
at your show right right but you know
and if you have some big followers and
you Peck out of room you better bring
that funny
social media will expose yeah man just
go do your skit yeah they might do a
skit [ __ ] that joke [ __ ] bro boo do a
skit where's the bad [ __ ] you have
the video right right
have you ever been booed on stage I've
never been booed well I've never been
booed on stage never and I'll be knock
on some wood or something come on yeah I
want to keep that streak goin out now
I'm not gonna sit here and say I haven't
bomb I've had those shows where I know
I've could have done better
you know how it is like once you reach
that peak of laughter that you want
every show it you don't get that you
feel like you feel regardless every time
me even the people have to show oh my
god he was crazy uh-huh yeah who's okay
yeah but yeah if it was so good why
didn't y'all give me that down laughing
[ __ ] you keep that's the part
because there are some people I've seen
that a show and I know have you seen it
- you're sitting there killing everybody
around them laughing everybody and this
is his girl laughing his homie laughing
he just like this oh the whole show are
you looking at this [ __ ] like I
gotta slap the [ __ ] out of you and then
was crazy as after the show he's the
first person to say hey man he was funny
as hell
yep [ __ ] why didn't you laugh
the whole room is laughing except for
your ass that's that's the rest of one
thing I hate I hate and we always notice
the ones that aren't like oh we're so
unappreciative we're the ones who dying
right right well we look at the one who
went last as soon as he laughs got his
ass now we satisfied why did we let that
[ __ ] win we can't let him take
our day [ __ ] we want that straight drug
we do more everytime you do bad
comedians are greedy
we're greediest [ __ ] have you been up on
the like the social media hustle like
did you you got a nice following right
but it's not like it's
hundreds of thousands right right right
like how have you been out even build
the following you have really man just
my following is wrong my phone really
fans like you know it's you have to look
for me you know I'm not verified I don't
know why I'm not verified but you have
to literally look for me I don't know I
want a blue check then right for seasons
on a television show they don't make any
sense why president be verified
have you tried to be like yeah I've had
I have friends who are on Instagram
board like close and I'm like hey I know
yes I Forge it and they they just I
guess I'm not a priority so anyway uh my
father comes from just wronged me a lot
of my father's from my state North
Carolina and New York which is where we
film weather now I think a majority of
our fans are and you know I'm proud of
my father when they ride with me they
support they buy you know I would hate
to have fine 2005 and nobody bought your
t-shirts no you know I'm barely hitting
80 but if I put on a t-shirt I'm gonna
sell 50 to 100 mmm you know I'm saying
yeah so you know I love my followers you
know and and at ninety percent of my
followers and I appreciate my following
because when I think when you get to
that five hundred 300 whatever you get a
lot of negative just unnecessary [ __ ]
and I'm cool with not dealing with that
right now you know I'm saying I would
rather have somebody like I love your
[ __ ] in or that's just like his [ __ ] who
are you where's your problem saying dude
I have like 3,500 followers right
I just transitioned into like posting
daily sketches and runs like right
I have already astir day I had somebody
make an account that was I hate Joel
buyers are you serious
3 500 followers and I think somebody
posted like you have less followers in
my middle school sister and all this
coming from somebody who has like 200
followers of course and then that's why
I blocked them cuz I just only want that
on the block-by-block hand is strong oh
I'm already learning yeah and like it
I'm I'm literally I'm a blip on the
radar and Instagram and somebody was
like making an I hate Joel buyers
account I was like we already made it I
posted my stories I'm like alright I
guess this is how it is crazy man is
really crazy I don't understand like you
don't much energy in time it takes to
select and then Selene and then pull up
your keyboard and type that you hate
somebody like that
if anything [ __ ] nobody's forcing you to
[ __ ] follow me yeah did you build up
through doing like sketches on Instagram
I think that has helped a lot of my
followers I've collab with a few people
whose heavy on Instagram Antonio's kids
Cynthia out in LA bank shot I've done a
lot of bad got me a big shot I've done a
few sketches he's played a big role as
far as helping that helping me learn the
social media game and yeah man you know
a couple of stuff with DC any time I
post a picture with Chico or Carlos it
goes crazy so you know they got they own
separate little yeah so yeah yeah and
one without help but I think this year
you know I made 16 out of 16 episodes
I'm on heavy promo and it takes like two
years or three years if you're not one
of the whilst our wrappers to catch on
when I think this is the year where
everything breaks out I was I was just
at the gym a couple days ago and the
lady in front on her TV was a wild and
out commercial yeah you were one of like
the main yeah people in the commercial
yeah that's love man straight from the
floor yeah straight from the face yeah
yeah and you get to work with
celebrities on all the time all the time
what are some cool opportunities that
have come from that the best thing that
happens for me for a while now is I got
a chance to smoke with snoop Oh bro I
smoked numerous blunts with Snoop before
episode that's hey I don't care what you
say hands down you can't top that but
I've met through Wilin out man I've
smoked with Snoop kicked it with Ray
Sherman had great conversation with
Erykah Badu met Jay Leno Timberland Iggy
Azalea Ti I mean this season we got 21
savage on there Wyclef the wu-tang
fabulous.i copy I don't know I'm trying
to think of everybody who who came
because I'm trying to run through my tea
grizzly came through mm-hmm and this was
a fun season man and one thing about
slavery's come on you know I come in any
celebrity who come to Wilin out cuz a
lot of them are scared a lot of y'all
are scared you know who you're scared
when the ones who have the balls to come
and kick it with his man
appreciate y'all so much we love it cuz
you got to put your guard down and have
a good time but so people so worried
about the image and you know can't take
a joke and you know they so terrified of
that [ __ ] but the ones who come on the
show put the guard down and have a good
time man my head
go off to you are you I can't even
imagine I've heard people's stories of
smoking with snoop and then the rest of
their week is gone the rest of the week
won't gone but the rest of my day was
fun I said you smoked before performing
on Wilin out yeah to me my my catch
phrase and while I was an energy guard
know when it's time to turn the lights
on I don't feel nothing I don't care how
much I smoke my adrenaline takes over
cuz like you've really got to take in
that moment like it's like when you buy
to go on stage and it's a packed out
house and you're and they're clapping
for you already don't even know who you
are yet they just clapping they ready to
have a good time when you step on that
Wilin out stage you look across and
Chico beam is my brother we started
coming together yeah I'm saying
Carlos Miller is my brother you look
across and you see them and they and we
none of us are social media people we
did you know we're not sketches as kids
we came from the ground we see each
other we like you ready to stop moment
that feeling that takes over your body
you can't I don't care how high you are
you're not gonna feel it now what's new
with the episode was new idea feel it
because his weeds a little different is
we thought yeah but that moon rock
tonight but he uh when when when that
hit you man and you know Wilin how fans
are the greatest fans in the world land
and lay they are lately in a feast like
eyes big ready and you can't you can't
let them down you can't let the moment
down cuz you you're you're basically
having fun on television
wait what can be hard to translate is in
stand up and maybe if excuse that that's
a was my drug dealer yeah he's outside
yeah he's got the plug I got a a 458
wait when you're doing stand-up it not
all the shows may be packed it may be
like 15 people right but you still have
to hit that let's go gotta hit it
what do you where do you go mentally or
I mean that's something I struggle with
is just hitting that level every time
what are some of the things that help
you I think honestly man with me
stand-up is just 100 percent confidence
okay and it's it's cuz you can actually
have no material but if you confident
they don't know that you don't have
nothing the crowd I never know
and the one thing about shows with 1512
people that's what you get your strength
in that's what you get your muscles at
because it's so hard to make ten people
laugh versus a thousand because thousand
will a crowd of a thousand people
they're hidden they did they feel more
secure you know nobody's really looking
at them they laugh and you laughing its
louder but when there's ten people is
hard because you know you feel like all
eyes on you commit reduce a crowd of ten
people they feel like us yeah we're
looking at them they're looking at us
don't talk about me don't talk about me
and that's where you get your muscle
from and that's where the Jews come from
so like there's I have the same
mentality with a crowd of 1012 people
[ __ ] it you're gonna get this [ __ ]
work let's go and then once you're
snapping at it you know and then you get
ten people on your side and you win a
show like that you can take that same
set and go murder a whole theater oh
yeah the the big crowds are fun just
because you can almost there'll be
moments if it's like a thousand or
whatever you can hear where the laughs
start right and it'll of grow to grow
across right right is wild but it yeah
the ten that's where yes well yeah
that's that's the muscle that's that's
what you did you think about how many
times you've done a room cuz I know
you're in Atlanta yeah I have open mics
six times a week
yeah no doubt but you do a room you do a
room with seven ten people in the crowd
think about how much new material you
came up with that night just cuz it was
that small mm-hmm just cuz you're having
conversations with people that tight
there's nothing better than that and
that's and that's the that's the true
art of standup that's the art that's the
art to make ten people laugh in a bar
where they're serving drinks they're
eating it's all these distractions the
gang zone and you still got these ten
people engage with you they not only
phone they don't look at Instagram
these two you see these ten people are
locked into your world that's the best
part about our job how disciplined are
you in developing material like do you
record all of your sets do you like help
me write because I'm because I'm such an
improv like off the off the RIP yeah
it's really hard for me to be structured
and I the reason why what works for me I
don't want to be too structured when I
come around material because you never
know what somebody in the crowd will
gonna say and they take your tangent off
to a whole new subject you won't even
think about you may have like you want
to be too intense and and you talk about
girls
relationship my girls to be like well uh
well white boys don't cheat why black
guys leave now you got address that
whole [ __ ] you know I'm saying you don't
even think about what you did or not
what if you didn't have what if you what
if you won't capable enough to freestyle
that now you go you just ignore that big
moment and keep going on what you
talking about here so taxes so that's
best you know that's where my material
comes from chopping it up with friends I
don't really go out looking for material
my material comes to me like I like to
smoke weed with women and that's I get
so much material from that because my
biggest fan base is women what women
want to hear [ __ ] about women so if I'm
smoking with a lady and she start
telling all these secrets it's like yeah
come on keep going yeah so y'all do what
you do what else you do why do you go to
the bathroom together yeah you don't say
and that is you know yeah you take that
to the stage like okay ladies I know
what y'all do I figured it out I know
why you go to the bathroom together and
then by that time all of is like how
does this [ __ ] know mm-hmm they're
engaged yeah do you are you trained in
improv or this has all been natural
that's real funny class clown and all
that you know honestly that's where I've
never took an improv class while
announcing profits just something
naturally you just as natural God gave
that to me I can't explain it it's just
something not just I'm quick on it
I got a reaction you know being a good
performer is one thing but the booking
end is something and the tours even
setting up a tour and you've you've been
on a lot of booked a lot of shows I mean
what kind of insight do you have into
that whole game man it's all about to me
as far as a booking one the best thing
to go try to get booked at is colleges
okay all colleges got to account where
they have to they every every college
can't afford Kevin Hart but they have a
budget of like 10 to 15 where they gotta
allow for some kind of relaxed
relaxation for students and comedy is
the best thing so naca after all these
programs that's the best way to start
especially you have a strong college set
you have a strong set for anybody young
and you can relate to them you're good
but as far as like these clubs man that
stuff is hard it's just hard cuz clubs
want people would have million followers
but then you booked them and then ain't
not funny
but this is this is what I learned this
is the conversation I like to have a
club good yeah I was just checking to
make sure it's recording yeah is this
where clubs I don't think it's the comic
job to fill up the seats our job is to
make sure whoever you bring in there has
a good time
yeah and that's where the
miscommunication has happened that's
where things has fallen apart it's not
the comics job to promote and post the
flier and tags that's not our job we do
that because we want people to be there
but it's your job as the club to send
out these text messages sending out
these emails seem that easy Viet bright
so these these Groupons and find a way
to get people in there our job is to
make sure they have a good time to leave
out mm-hmm
and so we're not marketers we're not
promoters we're comedians you know
saying I just happen to know how to
market you know saying so yeah I think
that's the biggest issue in today as far
as like booking anything clubs want you
know hey can you how many followers you
got well why does that matter I'm funny
here's some clips tell me what you think
let's go from there so for somebody that
doesn't have those followers that's kind
of like the key to the gate right now
what how do you how do you market you
said you know how to market I think the
best way to do that is men is a hit
these clubs up and you know tell them
give you an off night I didn't tell them
to help you out so I'm gonna give you a
night where you know you ain't gonna
make no money and I'm saying and and the
thing about being a comedian yeah I
think you have to invest in yourself you
may not have a lot of funds but there's
a way to pay the promote to get your
stuff out there you know you have
facebook you can you can you can set up
your Facebook to send an email or post
to certain people in that area you may
have to put a hundred dollars in it but
if you want people in there you'll do
that you know they could set up sponsors
and set up average times on Instagram
now $10 and $1 put that that one clip
that she made it was funny and to put
that in people's faces all day hey come
see me at so-and-so and you go from
there so you say you on an off night if
a comedy club get a hundred people in an
off night they're happy and [ __ ] so then
you go from there like so you saw what I
did on a Wednesday try me for a weekend
and then if you get a weekend that's
when you call your homies that's what I
call Tyler that's not called Ronnie hey
man
y'all funny I'm funny let's make some
money together yeah that's how I happen
and not only is the tour let me you guys
are on this big and bigger tour yeah
even like booking out the dates
like where do you just call up these
clubs how to even make the connections
for comedian trying to book their own
tour well luckily we have Ronnie and
Ronnie has all these relationships with
a lot of club right and it starts with
him okay hey Ronnie you got a
relationship with start on right yeah
yeah well call me let him know you got a
tour going you'll call them hey we got
to do four wiling out as well which one
okay I heard a big baby okay we're also
Minotauro Bossa TV so all that
conversation helps yeah all that helps
yeah I'm just coming
yeah with a podcast but hey but you're
up but you also have some of your
advantage you're white and you're funny
ooh true that you know I'm saying so so
you know there's always if you gotta use
that stuff to your advantage to be like
hey I could rock a black room try me
yeah
rock they world you do it you can rock a
black room okay not it thinking you know
I'm saying what can we do to make this
work you know say and and in my case it
would be dope if you got up with another
rising comedian and y'all get like a not
a black versus white tour but I thought
something was something like white
thoughts black comic black comedy or
somebody something like that you it will
be genius cuz you will bring the white
people who want to see what you talking
about
and then who are fans of comedy and then
you introduce you to a whole world of
the black audience there's like that's
why boy is funny so that's all you want
to hear you know I'm saying and so
that's I think that would be the best
bit it's all about Bridgette and you're
in the best place for it to work man
Atlanta
yeah I've never have never seen the city
that comes together and work together it
don't like it learn in my life and
you've been everywhere and I've been
everywhere what do you think it is about
Atlanta that I don't know it's the south
man I don't know I don't know man like
you know I'ma be honest with you like if
this was somewhere else and you had
before a podcast okay alright we'll get
up but you know I've seen you before
Tyler vouchers for you Ronnie vouchers
for you we've crossed paths absolutely
let's make it work that's the Atlanta
culture you know I'm saying yeah yeah
after this podcast it's not like I'm
gonna this podcast to be done I'm a
follow it my brother gonna follow it we
bought the Train oh geez we brought you
I'm in the city link up
that's what Atlanta brings you want to
see I want to see you make it the same
way you want to see me do my thing I
want to see you do your thing cuz I know
you're funny as [ __ ] and you deserve it
that's what Atlanta brings
whoa you don't get that in New York it's
everybody's economy even a [ __ ] who
work at the bodega yeah I do stand-up on
Tuesdays oh yeah
yes are you are you living in New York
no I live in North Carolina me
so you just travel up there for the show
how come you yell they just put you up
at all yeah put herself about a couple
of weeks yeah oh man I figured you had
moved on now
yeah New York is - I'm not a New York
person but I can't live that tight in
the room and overprice house and I'm
just I'm really content with the south
and if--and
I feel like I've kind of been spoiled in
my career because I made Wilin out you
know and I found out hi entertainment
works early and if you're talented
enough they'll fly you out oh you ain't
got a move that's been mine that's been
my kind of motive and just staying in
Atlanta not moving to LA or right it's
almost like if you're good they'll find
me they'll find you yeah gonna fly you
right on out
I've been flown out for auditions you
know I've been flown out when we did the
MTV Awards like if you're good they will
fly you out you don't have to you know I
I just don't see the point in moving to
LA or New York going broke trying to
make it yep especially now that's the
big that's a big you know that's that's
a big contradiction like oh I didn't try
to make it and all you're doing is
becoming broke just starting over really
starting over I didn't I realize you're
still in North Carolina man that's super
motivating and yes you can yes yes I
don't see me leaving the state at all
because one I don't have to be the
big-time comedian as long as I'm able to
provide for me and my future family one
day and travel every night then I'm
content you don't have any like
celebrity aspirations like hit on that I
mean it to me you're a celebrity but you
even said you know I'm not on that next
level yeah I just I just I just want to
be comfortable man yeah not struggle
financially what kind of goals do you
have professionally as far maybe your
own show ring Oh honestly my next go now
is to do my HTPC you comedy tour well I
took tour all because I graduated from a
historically black college mm-hmm and
and Jessica knows like 30 or 40 in the
US and just doing a real live tour
getting somebody to film it
follow the sleep on the road waking up
on the road gas station stops you know
everything that that goes into a tour
and I want to put it on Netflix that's
my ultimate goal that's my goal in the
next two to five years they have that
document and have that on Netflix like
just the energy of walking out of the
HBCU and walking out kicking it with the
students and the bands and you know
there's just certain cultures the HBCUs
they have the band the modeling troops
that Greeks the step shows all that and
just showing the world like hey this is
this is my people that's how we do
hashtag for the culture for the culture
am I allowed to say that yeah absolutely
all right I don't want to appropriate
looks like sometimes I forget what I
look like
like I'll go into like an urban room and
then realize okay you got to warm it up
in here you can't just come here I'm
sorry guys I'll have to address I had to
do that last time I featured uptown I
just said something that was like too
far like I was oh it was Sunday show I'd
been killing all week and I like ya know
I like to walk the line on just like
racial and just like progression rightly
commenting on things that are happening
right I was talking about I said
something like mm I said yeah black
people are a rising stock in his way
shut down right there it was a
compliment like Oh like I mean it's like
people are blowing up and what people
are a plummeting stock and I understand
that but it didn't come off that
heartedly and I had to be like guys I'm
sorry I know what I did was wrong I
apologize can we move forward as a team
and we like broke it down we aren't on
three they reset see that's how you go
but that's that was a yeah exactly
cool so that was just my racial diatribe
it's hard being white but anyway
obviously that's death-sphere my mind
said that's a sick because you could be
like hey guys yall you know out like
white people got it easy like you know
how hard it is for me when kodak black
drops and i gotta try to clap on beat
like that that's that's i could say it's
so hard being why it's so hard to just
you know
I'm playing basketball hey guys I can
dribble too you know I'm saying yeah but
you go white without the privilege fat
white like walk around getting
stereotyped is a good tipper diet why oh
man I appreciate your time driver I
appreciate it bro I know your time is
super valuable especially though I got
going on so before we land this plane
yeah is there anything else you want the
world to know a man a big and bigger
tour still going freestyle funny just
going Wilin out come back November 30th
season ten I'm on all 16 episodes
looking to do some more writing for TRL
you know keep working hey I just want to
tell yo your father was real people's
and there's anything that you think
about everyday go do it
period point blank I don't care if it's
UK you can't stop thinking about singing
dancing cooking whatever you want to do
it can it's possible to happen I'm from
Southern Pines North Carolina not a big
city small town there's no way in the
world I'm probably on the national wide
television show so if my country s can
make you happy
any of y'all can make it happen and
that's real how did you calculate that
big leap though for somebody who's like
oh I want to pursue this but I need to
be realistic keep my job save up like
how did you calculate that transition um
I just made a decision because like you
know what it was they be honest I when I
got on stage my first time doing
stand-up I did good and that's what
pushed me mmm that them laughs because
you know like it's like a drug no doubt
it's not the drug if you don't get on
stage like as you go like two weeks
without being on stage I mean you really
start you start feeling down a little
bit like I almost depressed because yeah
we as comics we feed off people's energy
that's what keeps us going
that's what makes us continue to do
these dumb ass drives and these open
mics after work and that's what keeps us
doing because that is a it's a genuine
drug making people laugh people say
laughing is the best medicine or
providing that you know is the drug and
the provide that we need your energy
that's all that we were able to provide
it so you just got to cut the bug count
the bug I caught the bug and then every
night I would be like yeah you know say
like when can I hit open my I just want
to make more people laugh I got funded
on this what if I want done that if
you're laying in your bed and
night and I want to think about that you
go ahead of doing it yeah and whatever
your passion is if you're thinking about
it definitely go do the work towards
what's the worst that could happen what
you [ __ ] make it boom
well I feel like we made it I'm getting
interviewed Aaron brain man I damn right
hey I appreciate you bro man all right
Jordan all right it's happening today we
got to link up the game already let's do
it that's facts already yeah any time I
say like a black saying it's like a
laugh
[Music]